Scott is with us in Chicago hey Scott
how are you it's taking my call this
sure what's up
so I'm on day you step number two and
the thing that seems to be doing me the
most trouble and the most frustrating is
I have fifty thousand dollars in student
loans
so let's need to be paid back over the
next 20 years actually so I pay at the
minimum coming out which I don't plan to
do but so cost me over a hundred
thousand dollars
that's absurd it's not even an option
yeah so what do you make oh well I make
on a thousand good so how fast are you
know fifty what's that
so how fast you're paying off fifty one
year I will I guess my question is why
they don't drive off why not okay why
not pay I'm not to that payment yeah I'm
so going off a couple of other things
oh okay so you got other day how much
other dad have you got cool but you make
one hundred grand are you single
no engaged oh good good cool when you're
getting married December 2nd oh okay you
haven't pay for part of that no good
good so so basically we've got from now
into December making a hundred thousand
dollars and you got about fifty four
thousand dollars fifty five thousand
dollars where the dad is that right okay
so you're not quite gonna make it in a
year but you ought to make it in 18
months shouldn't you well a hundred -
well let's just say 18 months 150 minus
60 is 90 you can't live on 90 in the
next nine eighteen months not counting
taxes I guess I lost you there somewhere
okay let me try again you make a hundred
a year okay so a year and a half of
income would be a hundred and fifty
wouldn't it right
- 60 worth of debt would equal 90 - type
- some taxes right - some taxes but you
can't live on 90 over 18 months no
you're right I am not at all no no
you're you're broke man you're not
invested in retirement you're getting
out of debt not even if it's not dude I
don't care if it's matched 20 times over
you got $50,000 in student loan debt you
just call me up whining about paying it
off over 20 years we got to change that
if you'll get this out of the way your
most powerful wealth building tool is
your income and right now it's all
committed to somebody else I want their
name off your income in the next 18
months then you're in a position to boom
man you could smack the crap out of that
401k after that right does that make
sense to you yeah just leave it there
but stop adding to any retirement
temporarily Wayman you're a new you're a
new listener right yeah okay I'm sorry I
was treating you like an old listener
I'm beating you up I apologize okay so
here's the thing we teach a thing called
the baby steps where you do one thing at
a time
in order in with the premise the
premises of this that your most powerful
wealth building tool is your income if
you have no payments you're in a
position to build wealth very quickly
and very easily and that includes
building first an emergency fund of
three to six months of expenses so baby
step 1 is $1,000 start that's a little
starter emergency fund baby step 2 is no
life scorched-earth lifestyle or
cleaning up debt because we're gonna be
we're gonna be so intense and so focused
and get it out of our life as fast as
possible because you have sixty thousand
dollars of barrier between you and your
dreams and I want it gone boom ponch it
okay and when you knock that thing out
then that set you have to go back to
that thousand dollar raise it up to a
fully funded emergency fund by the time
you do that you're married six months so
okay and you got her income in the mix
which is going to change the equation
here but I'm just using this as an
example three to six months of expenses
are set aside and now you've got a fully
funded emergency fund let's call that
twenty thousand bucks and you have no
payments in the world does that feel
pretty good yes now you step in and you
don't take the measly three percent
match in the 401 K you max that puppy
out or you take it up to fifteen percent
of your income then we'll save up and
pay off your house next and with no
house payment holder you everyone cool
by the time you're 40 you should be have
your house paid for and all this stuff
cleaned up and a paid for house and dude
you'll be a millionaire by the time
you're 45 if you do that guys the math
works I'm not making this up I've done
it before so here's the thing well you
and your fiance are getting married in
October you said yeah okay so we have a
nine week class called Financial Peace
University you go once a week one night
a week for nine weeks and it shows you
all this stuff and it shows you how to
handle money it's not get rich quick
it's get rich slow it's the hard way to
do it but it works every time and the
number one cause of divorce and money
fights in America is our the number one
cause of marriage fights in America is
money and money problems so I'm gonna
give you to that class as my wedding
gift and I'm gonna show you exactly how
to do this stuff and then you call me
back if you've got any questions I'm
gonna pay for you to go
hold on Kelly's gonna pick up we'll get
you signed up and get you going
boom we'll get this whole thing started
out there guys it's amazing if you just
take a step back in that interesting how
you think 20 years I'm gonna be in debt
and then one conversation in some basic
math and you go hey hey wait a minute
I mean I don't get rid of this now the
highest probability chance you have to
building wealth is to be debt-free folks
your highest probability chance of
getting out of debt is to be very
intense very deep cuts and do it fast
band-aid off quick snatch that's the
best way put it so that's how you don't
take it off slow snatches you get after
it
that's the highest probability of
getting out of debt which then gives you
the highest probability of building
wealth and being outrageously generous
throughout your life and being in
control because you have to learn to be
in control to pull this stuff off but
hey nobody wakes up a millionaire goes
how that happened it was accidental no
it's intentional steps people this is
the Dave Ramsey show hey guys thanks for
watching if you enjoyed this video click
the subscribe button to get the latest
content and check out these other great
clips from the show
[Music]